well joining me now is labour's shadow
foreign secretary david lammy good
morning mr lammy
you had um a good result in wakefield uh
does that mean labour's on course to
form the next
government well the result represented a
12.7
swing from the conservatives
to labor you know trevor that we won't
be forming the next government unless we
persuade people not to vote conservative
but and to vote labour that's what
happened in wakefield and if that result
was replicated across the country i
would be foreign secretary labor would
in fact be forming the government so it
was an excellent result we need to win
in those so-called red wall areas seats
that we lost in 2019 we need to pick up
right across the country very pleased
with that result on thursday
well it's great in theory isn't it and i
think you acknowledged there that though
it's a boost the chances of that
happening
nationally uh in every constituency
don't look so good for example
tiverton you came second there in 2017
and 2019 this time
the conservatives were defeated largely
because you lost your deposit um it
doesn't look to me
from these results that actually you are
on course for that victory
trevor we did well in the local
elections
we did well in wakefield the tories lost
in tiverton and yes of course there were
labour voters there that lent the
liberal democrats their votes so that
they could see the back of the
conservatives right across the story
this
this cycle
this wakefield result tibetan and in
fact the local elections are people
turning away for the conservatives so
the story of the night was this is a
very very sorry night for the government
indeed labor is on its way back and it's
on its way back for two reasons one
because we are now the party of change
in this country you've just interviewed
brandon lewis it's jammed tomorrow and
very little today for most people uh in
the country and two because we are
winning tory votes people who voted tory
now voting labor that's what we need to
do to form the next government and that
is what is happening
well you you just said a rather
interesting thing you said that um
people had lent
labour had lent the liberal democrats uh
their vote which presumably means that
general election uh they intend to uh
cash it cash those votes in and and take
them back so what you're essentially
saying and
pretty much everybody uh who is expert
in this agrees with this that what we
saw this week was the return of tactical
voting
why not why doesn't labor
look at the reality
and
start to think about at least an
unofficial pact between you and the lib
dems if what you really really want to
do as you and your colleagues say every
single day is get rid of this
whatever you describe it as conservative
government
i don't think the voters of britain want
politicians to stitch up deals
in the corridors of power people expect
to put their
make their own judgment
and decide who they want to vote for
in the end in the 22 years that i've
been in public life it's clear to me
that we have two major
political parties those political
parties are actually a coalition
in of themselves and for the labour
party to form the next government we
have to pick up votes from people who
are considering voting conservative
that's the basis on which we'll form the
next government i see
no possibility of us forming the next
government by picking up a few lib dem
votes i've got to be honest about that
or indeed green votes and that is why
i'm really pleased about what happened
in wakefield on thursday
okay so no deal with liberal democrats
but at one place you are absolutely
certain not to pick up votes on the
basis of both the polls but also the
actual votes that have taken place in
local elections and so on is scotland um
are you are you ready for
a minority labor government in alliance
with the snp
well actually
we've seen an increase in our position
in scotland under and asawa really
pleased to see us winning again in
glasgow uh in the elections just a few
weeks ago so i don't recognize that look
in the end trevor you're never going to
go back to where neighbour was in
scotland come on
you were the dominant forces that isn't
going to happen trevor trevor
trevor that's a very categorical
statement uh and and i've got to say uh
this is a matter for the electorate what
we're seeing right across the electorate
have been saying for the last 15 years
they they could swing in
they've been saying for the last 15
years we're making the snp
the government the snp will get 40 50
seats in the house of commons i mean
electorates are pretty clear where they
are
trevor
i'm not going to prejudge the outcome of
an election that's likely
in two years time
let's see where we get to but on that
result in wakefield and indeed in
tibetan we would be forming the next
government with a comfortable majority
that's what that result tells us
so you're not telling me no deal with
the snp
now
we've absolutely clear there is not
we're not striking deals with the snp or
the liberal democrats we want to win
outright and we will be fighting for
every single vote in every single
constituency right across the country
all right well let's talk about how you
win and part of this is
what do people think labor stands for
last sunday on this program mick lynch
of the rmt told my colleague sophie
ridge and i'm quoting here
i don't know where labour are if someone
could tell where labour are i'd be very
happy to hear it i think they're
triangulating between what they think is
public opinion in the light of the daily
mail and the commentary in this country
and i you know i can't do mr lynch's
voice but those are his words um
could you clarify for mick lynch i'm
sure he's watching
where does labour stand on his members
dispute and the claims particularly do
you back the seven percent rise and the
demand for no compulsory redundancies
well the truth is in the name we are the
labour party
uh where a party that's always been
concerned uh for working people's
interests working people who are using
our transport up and down the country
who don't want to see strikes and of
course working people working within the
railways
in the end we're not in government this
is a matter for the government network
rail and the unions themselves and what
we've been absolutely clear on is the
government should be leading and
encouraging negotiations not stoking
this dispute for their own political
reasons that's what's happening it's not
for labor to determine the outcome of
this but it is for us to say get around
the table negotiate none of us want to
see anger strikes
i didn't ask you what you'd do if you
were in government i asked you whether
you su whether the labour party supports
the demands of another part of the labor
movement for a seven percent pay
increase and the guarantee of no
compulsory redundancies that's nothing
to do with it whether you're in
government or not it is whether you
support the demands of another labor
movement institution what is the answer
yes or no
well just to say i i don't want
confusion for people listening the rmt
is not affiliated
to the labour party oh yeah the yeah
part of the labor movement
i've been clear trevor that it is not
for labor to predetermine the outcome of
this of course we're in a cost of living
crisis there'll be workers up and down
the country who want to see an interest
in their pay and this is not just about
pay it's also about redundancies uh it's
also about conditions there are a raft
of issues that workers are concerned
with right across the country it's not
for labor to intervene in each one and
pretend that we can negotiate or that we
are on the detail of that we aren't is
the truth of this and if we were in
government we would get around the table
we would not play union that is the
truth of being a serious opposition that
wants to eventually persuade the british
people they want to run the country
yeah i'm not asking you to intervene in
disputes i'm asking you whether you
support uh a you you said to me you're
essentially the workers party and i'm
just asking what your attitude is to the
demands of a group of workers because
you see what the problem is here it's
not that you are intervening in every
dispute but you don't seem to be uh keen
on taking a view on any of them
i i'm going to be talking to dave ward
i'm going to be talking to dave ward
communication workers union in a moment
his members have turned down the five
and a half percent offer of uh pay rise
from the post office are you going to
back them if they ballot
pro for strike action
every grown-up in the country
watching this program
knows that this is a negotiation
and i'm afraid it is not always the
position that one party to that
negotiation gets what they want it's a
negotiation and usually negotiation ends
in compromise that's the grown-up
position you know that trevor i know
that trevor so it's not for me to say
yes they're entitled to that seven
percent i recognize that there's a cost
of living crisis i recognize that
workers are hurting
and i recognize they've got a government
that's not listening that i do recognize
but it's a negotiation get around the
negotiation table and fix this problem
uh so the teachers when they have who
have submitted an inflation uh level pay
rise should negotiate and compromise
which essentially means that they should
settle from a below
inflation level pay increase
let me be clear none of us
want to see our school children after
the two years they've had during the
pandemic out of school
so i really hope that we do not see
strikes across our schools in this
country i really hope that a deal can be
struck
all right
okay let's go on to your own portfolio
it's become rather fashionable to say
that um we don't know what labour stands
for and i i want to give credit where
credit is due because on thursday you
yourself made a very clear statement uh
which you said we are not going into the
next election saying that we will enter
the single market uh or the eu
now um six years ago you said we can
stop this madness bring this nightmare
to an end through a vote in parliament
actually exactly the opposite um
it's perfectly right for uh acceptable
for anybody in politics to change their
mind but i wonder if you could explain
when you changed your mind on this and
why
well look thank you very trevor for uh
saying that i've been absolutely clear
we are not going into the next general
election promising to rejoin the single
market or go into the eu uh the position
is settled you know that i took a very
strong position
i was not for brexit i was what would be
described as remainer but quite a lot's
happened
in those six years we've had two general
elections we had the referendum
in the first place and actually we've
also got the withdrawal agreement we
stepped out of the european union and
i'm afraid the definition of madness is
doing the same thing over and over again
the british people have made that
decision it has now been determined uh
and
there are things that we can do of
course and i've talked about financial
uh equivalency for example we need a
veterinary deal with the european union
i i want to have an association with
horizon so our science doesn't lose out
in this country so there's a lot we can
do but we're not now rehashing the
debate that we had for the previous six
years well that's that's clear that that
one's over this very very quickly if i
may ask you will labour agree with the
prime minister that it's time to import
tariffs on steel imports to protect our
steel industry and the jobs they're in
i i saw this uh emerging news
i believe in free trade it's good for
everyone tariffs is usually a bad idea i
i've only just heard this news i'd want
to get into the detail but my instinct
is this can't be right
david lemmy thank you very much indeed
thank you